warning the following clip is from the
terrible movie batman and robin viewer
discretion is advised and you are poison
poison ivy i've been 50 000
for poison ivy one million dollars two
million five million that's a utility
belt not a money belt six million seven
million
never leave the cave without it we
didn't put that cha-ching sound effect
in there that is actually in the movie
this is quality film making just mwah
chef's kiss but can we just stop and
think about this for a minute how on
earth can batman get a credit card does
the bat cave get junk mail telling him
he's pre-approved for a card with a 7
million dollar limit also at that point
doesn't it just pretty much give up the
ghost when it comes to a secret identity
uh yes we'll start sending these
multi-million dollar bills to the cave
under wayne manor nothing suspicious
about that mailing address of course i'm
joking about all this but also i'm not
really joking you see batman tells us
all the time what he
[Music]
the is i am
batman you know what he conveniently
leaves out of that list though i am the
white collar criminal defrauding
millions of dollars from my investors oh
sure everything's all hunky-dory while
he's punching underprivileged goons in
the face when it comes to committing
corporate crimes batman is just as
two-faced as the rest
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's secretly funded by a
reclusive billionaire whose parents were
killed in an alleyway by unresolved plot
holes i don't know what you've been
thinking about recently but lately my
brain has been fixated about how masked
heroes make a buck it all began last
year when falcon and the winter soldier
showed us that an avenger might not be
capable of making ends meet how do you
guys make a living i mean your
financials are all over the place
there's a tremendous amount of goodwill
and people are inclined to help which
what even if the military contracted
private militia that is stark's avengers
aren't getting some of that government
dollar then dude let me introduce you to
patreon start a gofundme look if this
rando can ask for 10 to make a potato
salad and wind up earning 50 000 in
donos i think you're gonna be fine there
falcon spider-man you too now that
you're going solo post no way home skip
the whole freelance photographer for a
newspaper thing you're gonna make way
more way easier by just turning the
camera on yourself and becoming an
instagrammer own those exclusive rights
to those photos y'all anyway in the
world of superheroes getting paid one
person that never needed an explanation
was batman it's always seemed pretty
obvious right his parents were rich and
when they died he inherited their
billions which he then uses to pay for
his gadgets simple right seems like it
should be but there's actually a lot
more complication here than you might
initially think in anticipation of the
new batman movie that's coming out i've
been going back and re-watching the dark
knight trilogy and when you actually
follow what's going on in these movies
bruce wayne shows himself to be more
corrupt and more destructive than
literally any of the criminals that he
throws into jail it's only now that i
realize it because you know i'm an adult
who has to think about adult things like
taxes and now i'm starting to see all
the ways that he's screwing people like
me over oh yeah and in the process he's
also exposing a secret identity
it's gonna be a fun one friends if you
need any background on this uh it's
batman if you haven't seen bruce wayne's
parents get shot in the back alley by
now then let me be the first to welcome
you back from your 82-year coma you're a
medical miracle after the incredibly
wealthy waynes get killed bruce inherits
a massive business empire which
shockingly is not squandered by the men
running it during his adolescence this
means that when he reaches adulthood
bruce wayne is really really rich what
are your superpowers again i'm rich
while his depicted net worth has
constantly fluctuated over the years
it's usually trending upwards over time
to make sure that bruce remains one of
the richest people on earth in 2020 the
comics version of joker stole all of
bruce's money and punchline that's
joker's new harley quinn replacement
said that wayne was worth over a hundred
billion dollars surprisingly that's only
half of jeff bezos is there a joke to be
had there i don't know i'll let you fill
in the blanks the problem i'm talking
about though isn't the hundred billion
dollars it's that in the very same comic
punchline points out that bruce doesn't
personally own that much instead he
keeps all that money in shell
corporations to secretly move it around
and mask his vigilante activities this
started to raise some red flags for me
you see i'm interested in the films and
when you know it with this exact same
money scheme is explicitly talked about
in christopher nolan's batman begins
company went public a week ago and i
bought most of the shares through
various charitable foundations and
trusts and so forth it's all a bit
technical but the
important thing is that my company's
future is secure here's the thing those
lines make it sound like bruce wayne
actually owns wayne enterprises but when
you look at the reality of the situation
that is far from the case you see as we
just heard wayne enterprises just went
public that means it isn't just owned by
the wayne family or their small pool of
investment backers anymore instead the
company is now owned by thousands of
shareholders all of whom have chosen to
invest their money into the company
after perusing robin hood for like five
minutes they are all given legal rights
as shareholders rights that are gonna be
causing some big problems for old batman
here first of all shareholders have a
right to information since anyone who
owns stock in a company is considered to
be a part owner of that company it's
their right to see what the company is
doing with that money in the dark knight
we learned that wayne enterprises books
aren't exactly squeaky clean as his own
accountant mr reese puts it applied
sciences whole division of wayne
enterprises just disappeared overnight i
went down to the archives and i started
pulling some old files
don't tell me you didn't recognize your
baby out there pancaking cop cars on the
evening news oh sure watching the movie
we're all like be quiet lame numbers man
stop being a buzzkill but in reality
this guy he's the true hero he's
defending you know the everyday people
who invested their hard-earned money
into the publicly traded company that's
supposed to be operating above board and
he's defending it against lucius and
bruce the two guys who are cooking the
books doing a pretty bad job of cooking
those books too i might add this also
means that any stockholder doing their
due diligence on the company is going to
be noticing the same kinds of things
alarms would be raised by any
half-decent investment broker when they
realized that large assets were just
disappearing off wayne enterprise's
balance sheet every time something goes
missing from those books bruce is
stealing his shareholders property sure
he might own a sizeable chunk of the
company even a majority of that company
but there are still a ton of
non-billionaire investors who are
watching their retirement funds get
recklessly driven around gotham at night
a bigger issue with this kind of
behavior is insider trading which is
buying and selling company stocks when
you know that there's something being
mismanaged inside the company but you're
still pretending that everything is fine
so you can make a profit for instance if
you knew that company assets were being
stolen and disappearing but publicly it
told people to buy stock like nothing
was wrong or you know you had charities
you own buy and sell stock for their own
benefit that is big oof levels of
illegal there bruce thankfully it's
something that recent comics have begun
to address after the joker and punchline
steal all of bruce's money it exposes
the fact that batman has four years been
embezzling funds from wayne enterprises
every time he crashes a bat jet ski in
batman number 101 we see lucius fox
outright say quote i now have tens of
billions of dollars sitting in cash in
my bank account i could give it back to
you but it wouldn't be like it was
before the government now has its eyes
on you mr wayne you are going to need to
account for every penny you would never
be able to use any of it to fund batman
again end quote so this isn't just a
case of me overthinking a narrative like
i so often do this is an outright
reality of batman's story that the world
of dc is finally starting to acknowledge
and address and all of this is without
actually accounting for what bruce's
daytime activities are doing to the
valuation of his company as you may or
may not know stock prices are a general
reflection of the overall sentiment
people have towards a company sure while
they should be based purely on
statistical data around a company's
earnings production history of giving
shareholders dividends and how much or
little competition a company has around
it we all know that stock prices are
affected by all kinds of finicky
feelings from the general public
especially if the head of the company is
a celebrity for a company like say
general electric i would bet that most
of us don't know the name of their ceo h
lawrence culp jr can't think of a more
white guy ceo name living in the
northeast and playing racquetball at the
club on saturdays my point is he's a
rich and powerful dude but he's not
famous where he eats what he posts on
facebook because looking at that picture
tells me he's definitely using facebook
no one really cares what he's doing the
other end of that spectrum is our boy
elon musk ceo of tesla who can't get
heartburn without making headlines he's
a celebrity and he's done that largely
of his own making and it's clear that he
uses it pretty regularly to influence
people's opinions about tesla and by
proxy it's stock price a tweet about
solar roofs stock up three percent tweet
about how the stock price is too high
down it goes 10
is what he's doing technically illegal
no it's a gray area to say the least if
you do something that knowingly affects
the price of a stock but you either buy
or sell the stock right before or after
it happens in order to make yourself
money that's illegal because you're
manipulating the stock price yourself
elon is a person strongly involved in
tesla's business aware that his actions
both online and offline will move the
stock price affecting thousands of
individual stock portfolios retirement
incomes etc and he chooses to make
publicly controversial moves anyway
anyway i'm not going up against the
world's richest man today today who
knows what dumb content decisions i make
down the line anyway i'm not doing it
today the point is batman is not a
lawrence cult junior batman is an elon
the movies show consistently that bruce
makes headlines every time he gets
himself a new girlfriend does something
irresponsible in one of his sports cars
or donates money to whatever the
charitable organization of the moment is
probably a charitable organization that
he already owns and has gifted wayne
enterprises stock to his actions impact
people's overall perception of the
business that bears his name wayne
enterprises and his actions are always
for the worse it tanks the stock price
of the company so let's say that you
make headlines by burning down your
mansion and then you use those tanking
stock prices to buy up your majority
share now you're treading on some very
tricky legal territory and oh wait
that's exactly what happens at the end
of batman begins but the
important thing is that my company's
future is secure speaking of insider
trading bruce's use of charities and all
of this is again pushing the boundaries
of legality surprisingly using
charitable foundations as puppets for
your control is totally legal so long as
bruce is doing his taxes correctly but
using those charities to hold stock so
he can regain control of his company yup
that's where things get dicey many high
wealth individuals will donate to
charities in order to reduce the amount
that they have to pay in taxes at the
end of the year that is a fairly normal
and totally legal thing to do however
using a charity to hold your stock for
you can be seen as insider gifting it's
kind of like insider trading but with a
little wrapping paper thrown in to spice
things up consider this you donate all
of your stock to a charity when the
price is high knowing that things are
about to crash your charitable donation
actually winds up being worthless it
crashed but it looks great on your taxes
because you get to tell the government
that you donated all your earnings this
year when the stock value was high as a
result there are criminal penalties for
giving stock to a charity when you have
willful knowledge of a wrongful act
bruce of course knows that the face of
wayne enterprises is also a secret
vigilante who's stealing equipment from
the company to more effectively punch
crooks this is insider gifting 101. see
when everyone makes jokes about batman
being the real criminal of his movies
they point to things like him attacking
underprivileged goons or breaking and
entering into villains hideouts or
racing around town in his batmobile and
those are all certainly things that you
shouldn't dismiss in batman begins alone
one article is calculated that batman
commits a total of 68 crimes but what
everyone is always overlooking is that
his biggest crimes are of the white
collar variety embezzlement fraud
insider trading stock manipulation and
the prison time for this stuff can add
up quickly ranging from a few years to a
few centuries contrary to popular
beliefs billionaires can wind up in
prison take the cases of bernie madoff
and alan stanford two men famous for
massive ponzi schemes that wound up
stealing billions of dollars from their
investors both became billionaires in
the process both were sentenced to over
a hundred years in prison on the other
hand you have situations like enron
which in 2011 was the seventh largest
company in the united states some
corruption embezzlement and fraud later
the corporation goes bankrupt and
shareholders lose 74 billion dollars for
that the ceo of enron jeff skilling only
received 24 years in federal prison and
got out after 12. so like i said
punishments for this sort of stuff can
range a lot but it's likely that if
bruce were ever caught for all the stuff
that he does he'd serve much more time
for his business crimes as bruce wayne
than he would for all his non-murdery
vigilante crimes as the batman in short
make some changes bruce wayne
enterprises is a publicly traded company
and not just your personal piggy bank
not anymore sir and until you decide to
do that i'm listing wayne enterprises
stock as a very strong cell heck you
might even want to short it but that's a
story for another day but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cut
[Music]
you